[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
hey what is up guys mkbhd here and i've
always carried an iphone with me as you
guys already know but i've never been
much of a watch person like i've gone on
and off with a bunch of different smart
watches over the years that i've tried
the original moto 360 previous
generations of apple watch even the new
samsung galaxy watch that just came out
but always on and off with them i've
never been consistent with it
this one
looks like it might be changing that
this is debatably the best thing apple
announced at that latest event the
biggest upgrade for sure and while i was
there i spent all my time with the
phones but now i've gotten to spend a
lot of time with the watches over the
past couple days and
i gotta say it's about time we got
something like this
[Music]
so series four is the first real
redesign of the apple watch and it's
massively better in a lot of ways more
powerful more modern more functional and
just more fun it comes in two new sizes
the previous small 38 millimeter has
turned into a 40 mil and the large 42
millimeter has turned into a 44 mil so
i'm rocking the new larger one in space
gray aluminum and it's low key way nicer
than the series 3. now naturally when
you hear it's bigger you'd be concerned
about the watch being too big on your
wrist but basically the actual size of
the watch itself is nearly the same like
a couple fractions of a millimeter
taller and a bit wider but on the wrist
you don't notice it's like if you like
the old size you'll like the new size
but thanks to the bezels shrinking so
much you get a way bigger screen a 30
bigger screen area in the same size body
no notch needed that is huge every
smartwatch deals with bezels in some way
and this is a great way to do it it also
does have rounded corners which i'm not
as big of a fan of but it matches the
shape of the watch now and overall it's
a less bulgy thinner more modern looking
piece it's a bit thinner in that sensor
area on the back too and all the changes
put together make every previous apple
watch look terrible in comparison this
is the first apple watch that to me
actually looks pretty sleek there are
some other minor cosmetic changes too
this is the lte connected watch and that
huge red dot of paint from the last gen
has turned into a more subtle red ring
the sensor array on the back even they
don't necessarily look at it that much
is now ceramic and looks way better the
mic has moved from one side to the other
so it's further from the speaker that's
functionally better and the speaker is
now made way bigger but overall it's
still a familiar apple watch shape and
and the bands from the previous years
are all still compatible with this new
one and using the watch software is now
the same
but better meaning it's now watchos 5
which all apple watchers are getting now
and functionally it's the same it
doesn't do anything different it's still
the bubbly app launcher all that stuff
hasn't changed
but it's now better so it's on this
larger display already and then they've
made all the buttons bigger and easier
to press and all the fonts and texts
larger and easier to read so it just
makes the working surface area of the
watch so much bigger on your wrist to
the point where it's actually not a
horrible thing to pull out maps or open
photos up on the watch you can actually
kind of see stuff now if someone sends
you a link in imessage and you open it
on the watch you might not hate trying
to read it and apple's showing off these
huge new displays the best way they can
with some new watch faces that happen to
look super good on an oled display of
course with these inky blacks but
there's a lot of that by design there's
the infograph watch face that you've
seen like in the ads and all this new
promo material it has a ton of
complications in all four corners and
then four more in the middle plus an
hour and a minute hand and it's just a
ton of information
i
happen to like it a lot it's the one
i've been using some people absolutely
hate it it's like a crime against design
by the amount of colors people see
it's kind of meant to emulate those
super high-end watches with tons of
visible mechanical parts but a sort of a
more digital and more colorful version
i got the temperature in one corner my
battery in another the uv index outside
i don't check that or care about that
and my activity rings i don't know it
just kind of looks cool i like it i
don't know why you can definitely tune
it down though and there's also now a
new infograph modular face that's a more
digital version that still has a lot of
complications with a similar gradient
color style to each their own there's
also a new vapor watch face and a fire
watch face and a water one and these
were all made this is this is the part
that the video nerd in me absolutely
loves these were all made using
practical effects and recorded with an
actual camera so they actually made a
giant apple watch sized bin of metal
with a camera over it and filled it with
fire and recorded it
fun fact and probably the most
gratuitous apple thing ever i love it so
the bigger screen and the new design i'd
say those are the main draw the biggest
reasons to get this new watch but then
i'd say there are two other reasons one
the new specs it's a bit faster which
helps the s4 chip helps swiping through
the ui which you don't do nearly as
often as you do on your phone but it
used to be painful on the watch so i'm
grateful that they focused on making it
smooth now switching between watch faces
adjusting complications scrolling
launching apps all that and launching
siri is actually noticeably faster and
getting responses from her is snappy
there's also now just ways to talk so
you can raise the watch up and
immediately just start talking and it'll
quickly hopefully answer your question
if you're asking one so
how tall is the empire state building
empire state building is 1250 feet tall
when it doesn't work though it kind of
just looks like you checked the time and
then just started blurting out words
which is probably not the best look so i
definitely still prefer like holding
down the watch crown and and holding and
talking and letting go even though it
takes an extra hand and an extra second
so uh
how many feet is 100 meters
the answer is
328.08 feet that's fast and you could
probably also just hear then the speaker
is actually a lot louder uh the big slot
on the side i'd say it's significant so
if you're one of those people that makes
a lot of phone calls on the watch or
like gets a lot of responses from siri
or is just talking to it a lot or even
does walkie-talkies then that that
louder speaker will matter which brings
us to your final reason you might want
to get this watch
and that's just the sprinkling of new
features apple tossed in here and there
like the new walkie-talkie mode is maybe
the most gimmicky thing ever but in case
you want to talk to people on your watch
but don't want to call them there is a
walkie-talkie mode that you can enable
that lets you push to talk over and with
that throwback to nextel in the 90s i
think that falls in the bucket of
old people are gonna love this features
alongside fall detection
and ekgs fall detection is exactly what
it sounds like so it is after all an
accelerometer
and a gyroscope on your wrist so apple
tuned this and studied a lot of people
falling and with that if you take a hard
fall and then don't move for a while it
will automatically call emergency
services and notify your emergency
contact which is actually pretty smart
and i'd say an apple watch for someone
is way cooler than the pendant of shame
you normally see for fall detection i've
fallen
and i can't get up but also construction
workers and painters and many other
people who work at heights will love
this too of course and the ekg feature
is actually extremely impressive it's
not enabled yet but when it is you'll be
able to just hold down the watch crown
and it'll connect the circuit and the
watch can accurately read your heart and
produce an ekg that you can then export
as a pdf and send directly to your
doctor and it'll detect things like
irregular heart rhythm afib this is a
feature that when it's available could
legitimately save lives so the new apple
watch has a lot of things going for it
but it's not all great uh there's
definitely it's still very apple in a
couple frustrating ways meaning there
are some things that they could
definitely do with it that would clearly
make it better that they just don't do
there there is no sleep tracking at all
which you would think would be kind of a
big deal in a watch that's so focused on
health and fitness but it's not there
there's also still no completely custom
watch faces just the customization of
the ones apple made now to be fair
apple's made a lot at this point but i
feel like if apple opened this up to
developers and had an app store for
watch faces it could be huge right
you still can't use any assistant other
than siri of course i'm not surprised by
that but if i could switch it to google
assistant i would be so happy there's
also no always-on mode that i think they
could totally do with this battery life
and these oled displays it is as
consistent as ever with the whole raise
to wake thing but a lot of people i've
talked to want it to look more like a
normal watch even when you're not using
it and part of that would just be
showing a watch face all the time now
that would definitely bring battery life
down but it's already two to three days
that i get now so it'd bring it down to
maybe one day and that's not the end of
the world i think it would be fair to
give that as an option but at the end of
the day this is the best smart watch by
far all over again and obviously the one
to get if you have an iphone it's the
best productivity watch the best for
notifications and responses to them the
best fitness watch the best health tool
on your wrist now the price ranges a lot
based on what size what material and
then whether you go with lte or not
ranging from 399 all the way up to like
you could spend eight 900 bucks on this
thing i wouldn't recommend that but yeah
overall i just feel like i've always
been in this weird place where i know i
carry an iphone and i've always been a
fan of the apple watch but i never feel
like i'm missing out on anything when i
just don't have one but this one i'm
gonna keep on me i'm pretty sure biggest
upgrade to the apple watch yet and i
love it and i think if you're looking
for an apple watch you will too thumbs
up for me until the next one thanks for
watching
catch you later
peace